- So, welcome and thank you everyone
for joining us this morning.
My name is Reilly Hartigan.
I'm joined today by my colleagues,
Meredith Crawford and Laurie Toth,
and we're here to talk a little bit about
JIRA and Confluence
and how at the Yale School of Management,
we use that beyond IT, and for things
that are not technical.
So non-traditional uses
of JIRA and Confluence.
Perfect, much better.
So, before we begin,
I just wanna kind of gauge
who is in the audience.
So, if you have used JIRA
or Confluence before,
go ahead and raise your
hand...shout at me.
Okay! So, perfect.
Um, how about the other questions?
Do any of these apply to you?
You've, you know, haven't been able
to find an email when you've needed
to get some information.
Um, you feel like you have an ever-growing
to-do list.
And finally, since we're in New Haven,
how many of you like pizza?
Yes! Okay awesome, awesome.
Round of applause for New Haven Pizza.
So pizza comes in later.
I have a really
embarrassing thing to admit
but, uh
so if you're not awake right now,
you might be in about three minutes.
So, what we're gonna cover today
congratulations, you're
in the right session,
we are gonna cover first,
I'll take on what exactly these
tools are, then I will hand over
the presentation to my colleagues
Meredith and Laurie.
We'll talk a bit about why we use
these tools, and how we use them
day-to-day at the Yale
School of Management.
And finally, I'll be joining you again
to give some advice if any of this
um, you know, inspires you
you wanna go ahead and give this a shot,
give you some advice and tips
from what we learned.
So, without further ado, let's dig in.
Literally, pizza.
Um, and this is where the funny story
comes in.
So a lot of people are probably familiar
with the pizza analogy, um...
to describe workflows and we use
this a lot, people use this a lot
so I'm gonna use it again.
So bear with me if you've heard it before.
Um, but we're gonna imagine that
we're all running a pizzeria, okay?
And we have to do a certain amount of
things to get a pizza, from someone
ordering it, to getting that pizza out
the door, right?
So, we're gonna build
a basic pizza tracker.
And that's just going to consist of:
Someone places an order, it's prepped
so, there's a customer
one of you places in an order,
one of you is putting the toppings
on the pizza.
One of you puts it in the oven,
the other checks that it's good,
puts it in the box.
Someone delivers it, and someone's
lucky enough to go eat that pizza.
And now that we have this
beautiful pizza tracker, we can see
that we're doing pretty well in our
pizzeria, right?
We can see we're claiming a lot of orders,
so, some people are really picky.
Do the half of this, not with that.
Wish it could be simple.
And as things are going on,
we see an issue.
And we're able to
(background noise) because
we built this, pizza tracker
and here we have our customers saying,
"Yo, where's my pizza?"
and you have the manager saying,
"What's going on?"
And thankfully, because we built
this pizza tracker,
we can see maybe where the issue is.
So, there are no pizzas in the oven.
It's probably a problem.
Because it means we have no pizzas in
boxes, which means we have no pizzas for
our really sad customer over here.
And now comes for the real,
really embarrassing part that I
mentioned earlier?
I wasn't (mumbles) and I was like
let me use the pizza analogy to
describe a basic workflow because
we're in New Haven (background noise).
So my hand shot up and I said,
"It's just like the
Domino's Pizza Tracker!",
which immediately I was laughed at.
So, I've been vegan for four years
and I still sometimes order Domino's.
So, if you recognize that pizza workflow,
it looks a lot like this.
So, keep that in mind,
we'll come back later.
But basically, to come full circle.
I'm, uh, yeah.
I think the batteries have died?
- [Tech] Now you're on.
- (mumbles)
That's okay though, (mumbles).
It was green, now it's--
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
No, no worries.
So, apologies.
I promise this was not a ploy for me
to distract you with
extra time not at all.
Can you hear me now? Perfect.
All right, so, to come full circle
what are JIRA and Confluence?
JIRA is basically a pizza tracker.
So, we can see a basic workflow in JIRA
To Do, In Progress, and Done
and we just built
a custom workflow for
non-traditional use of JIRA
with our pizza tracker.
We have Order Placed,
our In Progress statuses with
Prep, Baking, Box, Out For Delivery,
and then finally a resolution of Done.
And, I'm using some of these words
because, again, a lot of you are
familiar with JIRA and Confluence.
So now that we've gone through that,
we can finally come full circle
and explain the analogy.
So, in this story of our pizzeria,
JIRA is really the pizza tracker.
It's tracking those items along
that workflow.
JIRA Service Desk is kind of,
embarrassingly, again, like that
Domino's Pizza Tracker.
It's really where the customer is seeing
you know, where's my pizza?
How long is it gonna take to
get to me?
What's the status of that pizza?
And finally, Confluence is a place
where we can all collaborate,
write pizza recipes, write guidelines
about how we work, and finally
a pizza can be anything that you'd like
in JIRA.
So to talk about those anythings,
in JIRA, I'm gonna
hand it over now to my colleague
Meredith, who's gonna talk
a little bit about what those things are
at the Yale School of Management.
- Thanks, Reilly.
Hi. I'm Meredith Crawford.
I handle editorial workflow for the
Communications Department at SoM,
and, uh
advance a slide here,
some of you might recognize this
as a basic, screenshot of Basecamp.
Before we found JIRA and Confluence
as a workflow solution,
we were using Basecamp,
which I think a lot of editorial teams
probably do.
And we were using it to manage
our communications projects,
which at any given time,
we probably have dozens of,
and they range in complexity.
So some of them are
really straightforward.
They don't require a lot of
complicated workflow.
They just go from
To Do to In Progress to Done,
but some of them have
a lot of different assets,
a lot of stakeholders, a lot of creators.
And also, we have a built-in processor
where we need to send our
content out to external stakeholders
for approval.
So, in addition to that,
we also have a Post-Publish.
So, once our work is published,
we also have another workflow
to consider, and that's how to
promote our content on social
and maybe, how to create something
on the website to feature it
more prominently.
And when we were doing all of
these things in Basecamp,
we were really limited
when it came to differentiating
the various tasks within one project.
Everything had to be under
one umbrella.
And so, we would end up with
these huge threads that sometimes
went on for months at a time.
And I mean,
you can see at the top of here
we have, 3,580 discussions.
So you'd have to mine your way
through that, and then
when you were working on a project,
say you were looking for a specific
asset like a video.
You would have to go through the thread,
and, god forbid you pulled
the wrong video, not the most
updated Word document.
So it was really confusing,
and we quickly realized that
it would be great if we could
find a workflow solution that
gave us a 360 degree view
of our projects.
A place where we could keep
everything under one umbrella,
but also take into account that
all of the various tasks and assets
probably had their own sort of workflow
to take into account.
So this is where
JIRA came into play.
And this is just the
very, very bare bones basic
sort of baked in JIRA.
Workflow that everybody has access to,
really.
And that is just, you know, gives you
a very simplified workflow
To Do, In Progress, and Done.
So, we started with this, and
we realized pretty quickly that
we had almost limitless options
in terms of customizing
our workflow process
for all of our needs, which is great,
but it's also a little daunting.
So, we spent a lot of time really
dialing in and trying to figure out
what we needed, what we didn't need.
And eventually for the editorial side,
we came up with this, and
you'll see it still includes some
of the very basic statuses that
you would get in a
simplified workflow like,
Open, the project hasn't been started
Assigned, it's in Draft mode.
We have, when we're working on something
we need it to be sent out
for external approval to a stakeholder,
so that's a status that we decided
we needed.
And then, ready to be put
into the CMS,
Published, and Done.
So this has worked really well for us,
and allows us to take into account
every point that we move content through
and, to bring it from
creation to completion.
This also allows us to include
post-publishing concerns like
social media promotion.
And the best part is that
when we create a ticket
to begin working on a project,
we can incorporate all the elements
that go along with it.
So, just by adding sub tasks,
we can consider various assets, like
if it has a video, if it has photos
that we need,
if we need to promote it on social...
that kind of thing.
And everything is kept in
one place, which is great.
And, in terms of keeping it all
organized, this is probably
my favorite thing about JIRA.
So, this is a Kanban.
I don't know how many people are
familiar with that.
If you're not familiar with JIRA,
I like to think if it as a very
non-technical person.
So I like to think of it of just
kind of a blackboard,
where everything gets aggregated.
And you can really keep it organized
by creating these quick filters,
which are when you label content,
you can then dial in and search
by the quick filter.
And you can see that everything is
in its own column.
So we have stuff that's still
waiting to be done.
We have stuff that's in progress,
someone's reviewing it,
someone's working on writing it.
We have stuff that's out
for approval, we have stuff that's
ready for CMS.
And then we have stuff that's
published, and what you don't see
on that is there are also some
other, customizable tasks within that
that say whether or not
it's ready for social, or
if it has been promoted
on social or not.
So we really really, gotten pretty
granular with that customization.
My favorite thing about the
quick filters is that
you can click on any of them,
and it will just give you
the relevant content.
So, I was in a meeting with
our MBA for Executives colleagues
the other day, and
we were talking about content that
was gonna go into their newsletter
and they said,
"What do you guys have in progress
"or that you've recently published
"that we can use in the newsletter?"
and I said, "Oh give me a second",
and I just clicked on
the EMBA Content label
and it gives me every single thing that
has been published, and it tells you
exactly what status it's in.
So, is it out for approval?
Has it just been published?
Have we promoted it on social?
So, that's all really great.
Happy to talk about that later.
And at this point, I'm gonna
turn things over to our colleague,
Laurie, who's gonna talk a little bit
about how we use Confluence.
- So, I'm gonna talk about how
and why we use Confluence.
We discovered early on that
Confluence is a great place for
Content Planning
and storing meeting notes and we also
soon discovered it's a great place
to collaborate.
Within the past year,
we started to rely on Confluence
for content planning.
It's and easy place for
multiple people from teams
across Yale SoM,
to collaborate on one planning document.
It also helps with Organization,
because we can keep all
the notes and discussions in
one area that everyone can access
instead of in someone's email
which might get lost or forgotten,
at least in my email (laughs).
It also makes it easy to keep
historical records.
This helps if your area runs
on cycles like ours,
with a few key events
like Commencement, or conferences
that happen each year.
By organizing and keeping our notes,
we can look back on what we did
the previous year,
determine if it worked well,
and then plan for the current year.
Now, speaking of planning,
we tend to do a lot of that.
For social media, we use
a planning document, which helps
us track what's shareable, and
when we plan to share it.
Each Monday, our social team meets
to discuss the week ahead.
Since we use Hootsuite
to schedule content,
we can decide what makes sense to post
on Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram, and LinkedIn,
and then schedule it.
Once an item is scheduled,
we can tick off the box
to indicate that it's done.
We also have a section where
we keep track of items that are
ready to share.
It's been extremely
helpful to keep these lists
to remind us of new stories, blogs,
or even media mentions of faculty
that we haven't shared yet.
We have found that we are able to
be more thoughtful on posts,
by being proactive and planning,
rather than being reactive.
So, as I mentioned,
we use Confluence a lot for
editorial planning.
From social, to newsletters,
to publications,
it makes it easier to communicate
and collaborate with multiple teams.
It also helps increase the transparency
of a project, and pretty much
what our team is working on.
Each month, the communications team
helps send four individual newsletters
for different admissions teams.
Once we added this calendar to Confluence,
it helped everyone realize that
their project is just one of many
that we're working on concurrently.
It also helps us plan deadlines,
and hopefully keeps the newsletters
spaced apart, so that we're not
in newsletter planning overload
at any one time in the month.
Whoopsie (laughs).
So, this is our newsletter
planning document
that Meredith referenced.
So, when we meet with
the admissions teams,
we use this document to plan the content
for the month.
By using a template,
it helps organize the planning process.
Once the content is laid out,
we can track the progress of the stories.
Many already have (mumbles) tickets,
but anything that's unique
content for the newsletter,
we will create a (mumbles) ticket.
Now we can keep track of when
an item is submitted for review,
and where it is in the
approval process.
In this example alone,
in that last column of notes,
you can see we have some items that are
Published, Done, Editing, or In Progress.
(laughs) I'm very heavy-handed in this.
You can also prompt milestones,
like we did for the newsletters.
Once a check is performed,
we can tick the box.
For newsletters, it serves as a reminder
of the steps that need to be taken
before the newsletter can be sent.
So this is a look,
just briefly,
of our collaboration space.
You can see we us it for
Print Publications and Alumni Webinars,
to Website Edits and Analytics.
We chose to keep
our collaborations in one project,
but you can break them out
into separate projects so that
only a certain team
can collaborate in that space
if that works better for you.
So, this has just been quick run-through
of how and why we use Confluence.
I am going to send it back
to Reilly for some tips!
- Thank you, Laurie.
Make sure my mic is on.
- (mumbles)
- All right, thank you, Laurie.
So, I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up.
We've taken a few bites
out of this presentation.
Sorry, I'm being a little cheesy.
But, now I'm gonna go ahead and--
(laughter)
Thank you.
Get some advice for teams
wanting to do the same.
Wanna go in and use JIRA and Confluence
for these non-technical uses, or
really beyond IT.
And the first and foremost piece
of advice I can give you is
to keep it simple, especially
to start.
And what that means, are those
workflows that you saw
that Meredith presented.
That first one that said
To Do, In Progress, Done,
and that all of the statuses can
transition to that status.
That's what keeping it simple means.
Get the folks
who are going to be using this
habituated to using the tool,
with a simple workflow that's open.
For those of you who speak JIRA,
and I would also keep in mind,
you know,
think about their (mumbles) case.
Think about how you're
going to provide value for that
person to use and to adopt
Confluence and JIRA.
How is it going to make their
job easier?
I think that's something that
we learned along the way.
Next, is of course,
do the legwork.
And this can mean many things.
This could mean
doing the legwork to get by and from
leadership, and a great way
to do that is go to Atlassian's website,
sign-up for a trial, build a workflow,
show what's possible.
And then once you do that,
instead of just,
"Hey, we should do this",
if you build it, and people really
see what's possible,
they kind of start to buy
in a little bit more.
And next, find champions,
and this could be people from
around the school,
around the university,
outside the university.
So, really anyone who's going to
go ahead and jump into JIRA,
jump into Confluence, and into these
tools with you.
And, I must say, you yourself,
if you are driving adoption
of this tool,
you need to take that first jump.
You need to be transparent.
You need to...
just go in
and start using it.
Start doing your work there
and people will follow.
Especially when they start
to see some of the benefits that
you might know and wanna communicate
to your team.
And, again, make sure it's
the right solution for
your team.
This was great solution for us
because, of course, these
Atlassian tools have a large
footprint already at
the Yale School of Management.
We're already using them.
We have licenses, so hey.
Why not use it for non-traditional
or non-IT uses?
Atlassian themselves actually do this.
So, really, it just made sense,
And it almost became like a
lingua franca between
our users, our folks in my department,
the folks who support
us and our developers.
We can all kind of speak this
common language of, "Cheer up!".
And, finally,
remember that
no tool is going to
solve all your problems.
You know, the tool is only
as strong as those underlying principles
kind of, undergirding it.
So, remember that this tool
isn't to replace conversation
face-to-face, or
conversations or communication
in any other manner.
No matter how cool or flashy
or what kind of automations you can do,
again, keep it simple
to start with.
Don't overwhelm folks,
including yourself, if you're driving
adoption.
And, again, really remember
this last point.
And with that, we are ready for questions,
which I'm sure you might
have a lot of!
- And the first answer
that is Handsome Dan in the
Evans Hall Courtyard (laughs).
(musical chimes)